we end this lecture sequence by stepping
back to discuss what probability theory
really is and what exactly is the
meaning of the word probability in the
most narrow view probability theory is
just a branch of mathematics we start
with some axioms we consider models that
satisfy these axioms and we establish
some consequences which are the theorems
of this theory you could do all that
without ever asking the question of what
the world probability really means yet
one of the theorems of probability
theory that we will see later in this
class is that probabilities can be
interpreted as frequencies very loosely
speaking if I have a fair coin and I
toss it infinitely many times then the
fraction of heads that I will observe
will be 1/2 in this sense the
probability of an event a can be
interpreted as the frequency with which
event a will occur in an infinite number
of repetitions of the experiment but is
this all there is if we're dealing with
coin tosses it makes sense to think of
probabilities as frequencies but
consider a statement such as the current
president of my country will be
reelected in the next election with
probability 0.7 it is hard to think of
this number 0.7 as a frequency it does
not make sense to think of infinitely
many repetitions of the next election
in cases like this and in many others it
is better to think of probabilities as
just some way of describing our beliefs
and if you're a betting person
probabilities can be thought of as some
numerical guidance into what kinds of
bets you might be willing to make but
now if we think of probabilities as
beliefs you can run into the argument
that well beliefs are subjective isn't
probability theory supposed to be an
objective part of math and science is
probability theory Justin
exercising subjectivity well not quite
there is more into it probability at the
minimum gives us some rules for thinking
systematically about uncertain
situations and if it happens that our
probability model our subjective beliefs
have some relation with the real world
then probability theory can be a very
useful tool for making predictions and
decisions that apply to the real world
now whether your predictions and
decisions will be any good will depend
on whether you have chosen a good model
have you chosen a model that provides a
good enough representation of the real
world how do you make sure that this is
the case there is a whole field the
field of Statistics whose purpose is to
complement probability theory by using
data to come up with good models and so
we have the following diagram that
summarizes the relation between the real
world statistics and probability the
real world generates data the field of
statistics and inference uses this data
to come up with probabilistic models
once we have a probabilistic model we
use probability theory and the analysis
tools that it provides to us and the
results that we get from these analysis
leads to predictions and decisions about
the real world